this is my first narrative feature it's
called every secret thing and I was
drawn to this film because it really
explores a lot of different themes in in
the guise of a really interesting
psychological thriller so I felt kind of
excited because there were themes from
all the documentaries that I've worked
on that were all condensed into this
film the idea that you can actually
organize the film and how you want to
make this film is something that you
never get to do and you make a
documentary because you're constantly
just you're editing and then something
happens with the story you have to drop
everything and go chase it and this is
kind of a different this is a very
different approach to filmmaking to what
I've been used to I have such a great
cast in this film I have Diane Lane
Elizabeth Banks Dakota Fanning Daniel
McDonald common Nate Parker all these
really talented actors I think they want
to work with me because of my
documentary experience and so we were
able to really do an interesting history
of each character and just get in there
and really find the truth and then they
were when they were on set they were
able to just let it go and just be these
these people that they were playing so I
thought it was a really interesting
process to bring my background into this
process into this film I think the film
really has to do with accepting people
for who they are and how we parent our
children this story is really
interesting it was very interesting for
me to work with Diane Lane who plays the
mother in this film who really who has a
daughter that she really doesn't like
and she has to kind of learn to just to
learn to be a better parent and she
can't so she just keeps making the wrong
choices and eventually pushes her
daughter into a place where she
basically is rebelling against her
mother she just wants to be popular she
wants to fit in with the group and her
mother looks at Dakota Fanning's
character and wishes that that's that's
who her daughter was so I think it's
really important to not live vicariously
through your children I think it's
really important to accept your children
and embrace listen to them and see who
they are and embrace that for for that
these characters are exceptionally
complicated and
you know there was a lot of judgment and
typecast in these these characters just
by the nature of the way they look I'm
more interested in like raw natural
storytelling that is emotionally based